dans la petite ville de novo pétrificat
au nord-est de Kerson le drapeau
ukrainien a chassé l'étendard russe même
scène à quelques encablures à David
hybride l'armée ukrainienne vient
d'effectuer sa plus importante percée
dans les défenses russes dans le sud du
pays
gloire à l'Ukraine gloire aux marines
ce 4 octobre 2022 David Yves bride a été
libéré des orques par la 35e brigade des
marines
désavancées notoires mais la province de
Kerson reste contrôlée à 90% par les
Russes qui viennent de l'annexer mais
c'est surtout sur le fond est que la
côte offensive ukrainienne est
actuellement la plus efficace pour le
président ukrainien ce n'est qu'un
débutamant dans le sud de notre pays
dans le cadre de l'opération de défense
actuelle des dizaines de villages ont
déjà été exemptés du pseudo référendum
russe organiser cette semaine uniquement
dans les régions de Kerson car kiff
louange et Donetsk
malgré cette série de revers cuisants
l'armée russe n'a pour le moment pas
annoncé de retrait et les autorités
appellent à ne pas paniquer Moscou
compte sur le renfort de la mobilisation
partielle pour reprendre l'avantage
à ce jour plus de 200000 personnes sont
arrivées dans les forces armées j'ai
demandé à ce qu'elle soit équipée en
vêtements et autres affaires et de leur
assigner
de son côté Kiev continue de recevoir le
soutien militaire des États-Unis la
Maison Blanche vient d'annoncer un
nouveau volet de 625 millions de dollars
pour aider les Ukrainiens à chasser les
Russes